so now we're going to see if we can
apply what we just learned about
elasticity and how to measure it by
cooking a steak we're then going to
measure the elasticity of a raw piece of
steak and a piece of steak that is
cooked about well or medium well and
we're going to see how the elasticity of
the steak changes as the steak cooks we
have a steak here and in order to do
this scientifically we have cut out
little pieces of steak and they're all
the same dimensions so there are 4
centimeters by 4 centimeters and we're
going to apply a weight to the steaks
before and after they're cooked and
we're going to see how much they
compress and then we're going to use the
equation of the week and see if we can
calculate the elasticity okay so here's
your little setup for how to measure
elasticity very simple you can even step
this up in your own kitchen so we have a
little plastic plate that we're going to
place on top of the piece of food and
then we have a ruler and then we have a
weight and here I'm showing you a 200
gram weight that we're just going to
place on top of the steak and as you can
see the initial measurement for this is
30 millimeters and it's a little bit
hard to see but then as we apply the
weight the 300 gram weight the
measurement goes down to 26 millimeters
so there is a compression of 4
millimeters so now we can just take
these numbers and plug them into the
equation of the week and see what we get
for elasticity so we know that our city
is stress over strain and stress is the
force over the area and we already know
what the area is because I told you that
each side of the steak is 4 centimeters
by 4 centimeters so that's 16
centimeters squared and the force is the
mass tent times the gravitational
constant so the mass is 200 grams that's
point 2 kilograms times 10 meters per
second squared okay and for our strain
we have the Delta L the difference that
we got which was 4 millimeters over the
initial height so that is 4 millimeters
over 30 millimeters so if we now just
plug all this in this is 2 Newton's over
16 centimeter squared and 16 centimeters
squared is 0.001 6 meter squared so we
need to make sure we go back to the SI
units and then we divide this with for
over 30 millimeters
so this turns out to be 9400 neuters per
meter squared so this is our elastic
modulus for a Ross week now let's go and
do this for a cooked steak which daniel
has cooked for us so here we now have a
cooked piece of steak and it's been
cooked to about medium well and the
forest is still the same it's 200 grams
times the gravitational constant whose 2
Newton and the area is 2 cm is 4
centimeters times 4 centimeters and as
we apply the way you can see how the
steak has compressed to 28 millimeters
so there's a change in there's a
compression of two millimeters so about
half as much as you saw in the raw steak
so now let's plug this into the equation
and so this turns out to be eighteen
thousand seven hundred Newton's per
meter squared so this is about twice the
elastic modulus as we saw for the raw
steak so the steak has actually become
stiffer as we cook the steak